[Music]
there's a saying amongst miners that if
it can't be grown it must be mined and
this is absolutely true for the metals
and the materials that we need for
modern lifestyles
demand for metals for all kinds of
metals is rising very strongly simply
because economies are reopening from the
nadir of colvit 19. that really boosts
demand for all sorts of things your
household stuff your refrigerators
including big things like if we are
building a new bridge or building a new
highway
they all need metals so demand for
metals is really rising strongly
nickel mining in particular has been
increasing in demand since the early
2000s largely due to china's economic
boom
and the rise of electric vehicles means
nickel consumption is only set to grow
a meeting demand for nickel means that
nickel mining needs to upscale in many
countries around the world and it means
expanding nickel mines using traditional
methods of strip mining which will have
an effect environmentally
and so with increasing demand comes
greater responsibility to minimize the
damage caused by mining and to search
for sustainable options
for the past 30 years researchers
worldwide have been pursuing a more
radical and eco-friendly technology
called agromining also known as
phytomining
growing crops of plants that absorb and
store metal from the soil that can then
be harvested
we have already worked with zinc with
the rare earth elements which are very
important for recent technologies and
it's also possible to recover cobalt
from this technology
but despite the success of this research
does aggro mining stand a chance against
the massive scale of conventional mining
and can it convince a legacy industry to
change its ways
i think they are committed i think they
have really good intentions to
mine their
products in a sustainable way
but ultimately i think mining is a dirty
business
while mining is necessary and has many
positive benefits must say that
it does have many negative aspects and
especially the impacts on the
environment
mine wastes our large
sort of volume of waste material
generated by mining
and these can be in liquid form
and they can contain very acidic waters
that contain a lot of metals and
metalloids that are toxic and so when
those get out into the water environment
they can contaminate land and water kill
plants reduce biodiversity
mining is also responsible for air
pollution from the dust generated during
extraction and the roasting and burning
of oars which can lead to acid rain as
well as contribute to emissions
surface mining also causes deforestation
as trees are cleared to make space for
mining sites
nickel mining in particular presents
problems due to its emissions to the
extent that in 2020 elon musk put out a
call for ways to meet nickel demand
sustainably
you may think steel is the most
polluting metal uh when it comes to co2
emission but actually nicole has the
highest co2 emission intensity of all
metals
co2 emissions per ton of metal for the
nickel production on average is about 18
tons of co2 per tonne of metal
nickel processing smelting and refining
also has the highest co2 emissions of
mined metals
i would say probably the actual
extraction of minerals and metals and
materials does the most damage
if you have a deposit that maybe
contains one percent copper these days
that means ninety percent is waste
material and so you have to clear that
to get to the one percent copper that
you need
so it's probably the extraction phase
that generates the most damage and the
most waste which therefore needs to be
managed
the mining industry is estimated to make
up four to seven percent of greenhouse
gas emissions worldwide
but mining companies are facing
increased scrutiny from investors and
regulators who want them to pay
attention to environmental issues and
commit to carbon reduction targets
the nickel industry is making
improvements to make mining more
environmentally friendly for example
some plants have been using renewable
energy hybrid systems as a fuel source
and indonesia
they are the largest producer in the
world
they also set up emission targets for
the next decade
but the industry as a whole is slow
compared to other industries
but the global demand for metals needed
by modern society means destructive
mining practices will continue if not
expand in the future
[Music]
but in the east of france there's a
group of scientists hoping to speed up
the pace of change
dr anthony van der ent is visiting from
the university of queensland
for the past 15 years he's been
investigating the power of plants to
harvest minerals and metals from the
soil and along with scientists from
across europe and asia he's been
developing a process called agra mining
so agromining is the process of growing
hype accumulated plants
on an agricultural scale in a type of
agricultural operation and not to
produce something that you can eat food
crop
but to harvest the metal from their
biomass
so hype accumulators are a rare group of
plants
that have the unusual ability to
accumulate very high concentrations of
particularly metals into their living
shoots so into their leaves we know of
about 700 of them that occur all around
the world
most of them are known for nickel 500 or
some of them
but we know hype accumulators for a
whole range of different metals
including tallium and zinc copper cobalt
manganese
but we keep discovering more of these
plants wherever we do research so
there's about 350 000 plant species
around the world and we think there are
more hybrid accumulators that avoiding
discovery
a nickel hyper accumulator plant takes
up the metal present in the soil through
its roots
it then stores it in the skin of its
leaves or biomass
after the plants are harvested this
biomass is dried and incinerated
the ash created by burning the plants is
then ready to be processed to create a
bio ore from which the nickel can be
recovered
chemical engineering professor marie
odile simanol uses a form of
hydrometallogy to extract the nickel
from the bio-oil
so here is the ash and the ash is very
rich in nickel it contains up to 20
percent of nickel that is more than any
ore on the earth
then nickel is extracted from the ash
the ash is first washed
and then nickel is extracted by an acid
at a high temperature
and this solution
is filtered to remove the ash and
recover the solution containing nickel
and finally we have a precipitation
stage in which nickel
is precipitated in the form of a nickel
salt for instance but we could do any
kind of nuclear compound
it could possibly function for many
other metals depending on we have plants
able to accumulate the metals and
develop the methods to recover the
metals from the plants but the first
step is to have the plants
[Music]
nearby at econics experimental farm
professor guillaume echevarria and his
team grow new varieties of
hyper-accumulated plants to be trialled
around the world
so here we are in
the economic experimental farm
this is where we prepare uh seedlings
and plants to transplant into
contaminated soils but also this is
where we
try to breed new varieties of hyper
accumulators to grow in greece and other
countries
this is a sedum plumbi zinc cola so it
bears the name of the metals where it
was found this is a zinc and cadmium
hyper accumulator so we mostly use it to
decontaminate contaminated soils
this is pelargonium capitatum and this
is a lead hyper accumulator
again to
decontaminated polluted soils
here we have the local zinc and cadmium
hyper accumulator noche
caroulescence
which is endemic from western europe
guillaume and his team carefully breed
and select plants to improve nickel
extraction from the soil with the goal
to double the amount of metal a plant
can absorb and store
so this plant is the most efficient
nickel hyper accumulator we have in
europe so leaves can contain up to four
percent of nickel dry weight
that means uh
when we ash them we can reach 29
30 percent of nickel in the ashes
that's the record
[Music]
while incinerating the plants uses
energy the team's tests have found the
overall aggro mining process uses
significantly less energy than
conventional mining procedures
these highly efficient hyperaccumulator
plants are also able to grow in soil
which is ultramafic containing high
levels of metals that can be naturally
occurring through rocks or contamination
from human activities including mining
traditional strip mining would also take
place
on land that has the very highest grade
of nickel
in contrast aggro mining can take place
on soils that are much lower in nicole
which are very widespread so for example
in indonesia the island of sulawesi has
over 15 000 square kilometers of
ultramafic soils
now perhaps only a small percentage of
that is suitable faggor mining but that
still represents a huge area that could
be developed
now the impact from aggro mining is
comparable to normal other types of
agriculture so it has a very low
environmental footprint that contrasts
quite strongly to strip mining in that
respect
ultramafic soils usually lack the
essential nutrients needed to grow most
crops so they're abandoned by
conventional agriculture
one of the more immediate benefits of
hyper-accumulated plants is that they
can help to clean up contaminated soils
provided their roots can reach the
toxins
installing the hyper accumulator plants
on this kind of material
is a kind of a nature-based solution
which allows the vegetation and the soil
fertility to grow quicker than if you
apply conventional methods of soil
rehabilitation
acro mining especially in the case of
nickel takes place in regions that have
poor soils because of their lack of
fertility
it can really be an opportunity for
small farmers to earn a living
then of course it's very interesting to
provide both renewable energy
opportunities and also the production of
a very targeted mineral or even
metallurgical industry
we think there's a lot of potential for
aggro mining to be undertaken by local
communities particularly in the
philippines and indonesia
where local communities could grow hype
accumulated plants much like any other
crop
on ultramatic soils
those soils or traffic soils are
typically not suitable for normal food
crops because they're highly infertile
and because the nickel in the soil is
toxic
so over the time that the fighter mining
takes place which you think is between
20 and 30 years the soy quality is
improved by increasing the fertility and
by decreasing the nickel that is in the
soil over time so at the end of the
fighter mining or aggro mining process
the soil is actually suitable
potentially for normal food crops
there have already been successful
commercial trials in europe for smaller
scale farming but the future of agra
mining depends on collaboration with
commercial mining companies
we don't think that aggro mining can
replace traditional mining of entirely
traditional mining takes place at huge
scale has very high efficiency of
processing enormous quantities of ore
talking kilotons of nickel in a year's
time for a single mine so we see it as a
supplementary form of producing nickel
with a very low environmental impact
alongside the traditional mining and
that needs to supply nicolette scale
typically on a mine lease only a small
part of the whole site will be mined
that is a much larger area that still
has nickel in the soil but which is
below the cut-off grade for normal
processing so in that halo around the
mining operation you could also develop
aggro mining as a complementary
technique alongside the traditional
mining
the challenge of course is to make an
economic business case
where the scale at which is could happen
is large enough and the products the
buyer valuable enough to make that worth
the effort
their technology does look really cool
really appealing but they are all at
very early stage they have not reached
to
mass production levels for example for
nickel we all know that we are going to
need a lot more nickel in the future to
be able to achieve the climate goals
pledged by automakers governments
and just like the world in general to
build a better future if those
technologies are cool are really valid
and
legit
they need to really kind of work out
mass production
if they get endorsements from those big
automakers and oems then that to me is a
big thing that means they are on the map
that will attract more investors
[Music]
it's taken a few years for aggro mining
to find this place and to be fully
validated the main challenges has been
to
essentially get it from a scientific
idea
to test it in the lab scale and in the
greenhouse and then to bring it to the
fields
many other species still remain untested
even though we think there's a lot of
potential
not just for nickel but also for other
elements that can be aggro mined
including cobalt and manganese and zinc
and selenium a lot of that has to do
with essentially finding the right
species
and then finding funding to set up
trials both in the lab and then upgrade
that to the field
agro mining is of course one of the
different tools we will need in the
future
besides secular economy recycling and of
course exploiting new resources so i
think in the future it would be great
that we can benefit from this knowledge
that has been acquired for decades now
and really use the potential of these
hyperacunator crop to really produce the
tremendous amounts of strategic metals
that we will need for the ecological
transition i think for
environmentalists they need to be aware
of that it's a very delicate balancing
act for for minors on the one hand they
need to produce the products we actually
need in the future and a lot of them
but on the other hand they also need to
be aware of the environmental impact
so governments are very interested in
these types of techniques to extract
metals and reduce toxicity and reduce
the environmental impacts
it very much fits in the circular
economy theme of putting materials back
into the system and reusing them rather
than just generating waste or having to
dig up new materials and i think we'll
see much more of it in the years to come
[Music]
you